good afternoon and welcome to at Yale
live I'm Eric gershon yell and New Haven
share nearly 300 years of history and
one keeper in chief of the highlights
she's with us today Judy ship is chief
research archivist at Yale and as of
last year New Haven's city historian
Judy grew up in New Haven and has worked
at Yale for more than 50 years with
intermittent absences for college and
graduate school at Barnard and Columbia
Judy's been called Yale's encyclopedia
and has written the Old Yale column in
the Yale alumni magazine since 1987
today we'll talk about a colonial
American College that became a global
university handsome Dan 19th century
collegiate baseball the dawn of frisbee
and we'll take some of your questions
tweet us at at Yale or email us at
social media at yale edu judy thanks for
being with us it's great to be here so
Yale and New Haven have been together
for almost 300 years the university's a
little bit older than that it didn't
start in the city of New Haven tell us
how it got here and why well the dream
of the college is so-called even pre
founding as some people have described
it did take place in New Haven with the
plan and the mind of the principal
founder the reverend john davenport the
group of Puritans who came first to
Boston and hope to settle there and hope
to found a college found that there had
already been a college founded there in
1636 and that became Harvard and so they
looked for a new place and I found a
wonderful place where the Quinnipiac
Indians lived that had a great harbour
and it took them a while to get the
college started but that was their dream
and what about the shoreline we often
hear about Yale really originating in
some of the shoreline towns Branford Old
Saybrook and so on did classes first
right tell us well it was really the
minister of New Haven James pierpont who
continued this unfulfilled dream of the
Reverend Davenport Davenport's dream
didn't happen because the colony of New
Haven was dissolved by King Charles the
second
it was added to the colony of
Connecticut and so it wasn't until 1701
when the area ministers 10 of them met
in Minister Russell's home in branford
and by a symbolic act of each of them
putting their most valuable possessions
their books on the table and creating a
library they said they found at a
college but this was not a legal college
so it had to have a charter which they
got in new haven at the meeting of the
legislature in 1701 but where was the
college going to go and that was sort of
a competition between Hartford and New
Haven and so they had a compromise
location which was saybrook now old
saybrook which was at the juncture of
the Long Island Sound and the
Connecticut River so it seemed like a
good place to start and classes were
held there until for some time yes the
college sort of began to fall apart as
early as about 1713 it never really got
a firm footing the first rector died in
1707 saybrook was such a small town
people didn't really want to go there
particularly and so it began to actually
break apart into small groups being
taught in tutors homes and so in 1716
they put out a call for a new home and
Yale outbid every place else in Haven
did New Haven outbid Hartford and so it
was decided by the corporation to move
to New Haven which they did in 1716
however it took awhile for a building to
be built and so 1716 is when Yale
essentially establishes itself in the
official vote to move to New Haven okay
and you say that the city outbid
Hartford that's right for the college
what do you mean by that out big was it
sounds like there was a content well
they actually met the selectmen in each
of these communities and the two largest
really being New Haven and Hartford the
they pledged up to about 2,000 pounds or
that at least that's what they said
and a lot of land and the land was at
the corner of college and chapel street
now occupied by Bingham hall across the
street from claire's and that was where
the first building was built but they
began to run out of money even before
the building was built so so that
building is long gone yes but although
that's the corner of old campus yes of
all campus today so presumably it was a
been a subsidy from the the palace of
New Haven that kept the university that
attracted it here and yes going
initially I mean all colleges are
dependent upon support whether it be
private or public and for many years
Yale enjoyed both and might be a good
time to talk about Elihu Yale comes
Bailey it would be although I want to
quickly ask you if there are any visible
signs of colonial era Yale physical
signs today well definitely because the
second building that Yale built which we
call Connecticut Hall is still standing
it's the oldest building in New Haven
it's in the center of the Old Campus you
can't see it from the sisters of red
brick building the red brick building
with the statue of Nathan Hale outside
Nathan Hale roomed in that building as
did Eli Whitney and James Hill House and
anyone famous who went to Yale in the
early days lived in that building back
to your topic certain general gentleman
named Elihu Yale who was he and how did
his family name come to be the name of
what today is Yale University well Yale
to begin with as the school had no name
it was just called the collegiate school
apparently maybe waiting for a donor or
at least keeping it kind of quiet so
that it wouldn't arouse too much
suspicion back in the mother country and
so when they were being great britain
Great Britain and so when they were
building the building as I said they
didn't even have enough money to build
complete this first building and one of
the men who took an interest in the
school Cotton Mather knew that Elihu
Yale was a man of great property and
wealth living in London
who had New Haven connections in fact
his father David Yale was a stepson of
the opolis eaten who was the principal
founder along with davon portable
founder of the colony of New Haven okay
and so David Yale had spent some time in
New Haven the father of Elihu grew to
maturity apparently went to Boston to
seek a wife and began to raise a family
there in the meantime Lu being born in
1649 that was when Oliver Cromwell came
into power and it was in England so it
was possible for these renegade Puritans
who became Congregationalists to go back
to England if they wish to because they
could practice their religion and many
many did and so the family of David Yale
went back to England and Elihu Yale so
did Lu you grow up in England set foot
in the city of you never came to New
Haven but he did know about his new
haven roots and in fact that was really
the one of the the reasons that they
knew that they possibly could get some
money from him because Elihu Yale had
only daughters they were married could
not carry on the name his he had had a
son who died as a young boy he brought
over a cousin also named David Yale from
New Haven that he was planning to
sponsor and adopt eventually but David
Yale did not like the young David Yale
did not like the lifestyle in Britain
and went back to New Haven he gave up
the chance to become a very wealthy man
in order to live as a farmer here and
what was what was le Hugh Yale doing for
a living that enabled him to be a
benefactor you about 15 or 16 as a clerk
in the East India Company and that was
just the beginning of East India Company
he amassed great wealth possibly mainly
because he was he stayed healthy
everybody above him passed away from
various tropical diseases and he became
the governor of Fort st. George at the
same features where that is that's in
the southern part of India oka at the
same time he amassed a great private
fortune by learning the diamond trade
from Portuguese traders and he
brought the diamond industry actually
back to England where they had never
really known about cutting jewels some
of the jewels were cut in the earlier
days in Holland so he had a great
fortune which would have come to Yale he
actually only gave a small token gift to
begin with that but it sold for some 500
pounds of valuables and that was a great
start for Yale at the time so they
quickly reprinted their commencement
program and this is in what year in 1718
continue September was when people used
to graduate from college so the
commencement program was quickly recap
reprinted as Yale College they had the
money to finish their building which
they also named building formerly at the
corner of chapel and it was a wooden
building a rather impressive building we
have do have prints of it and but it was
not a material that was long lasting and
it sort of deteriorated and was torn
down about 1780 but the name Yale stuck
and when Yale got its first official
full charter in 1745 the Yale name was
officially put on it it was known as
Yale before that though so the you for
the chief research archivist of
university for some time you've been
with the University for more than five
decades I have are there well let me let
me let me ask pass long question from
from a viewer chianti roman who wants to
know a little bit about what your
favorite relics in the manuscripts and
archives are and i guess i would add to
that are there any that that relate to
colonial era Yale yes there are many
artifacts you might compare manuscripts
and archives and we are in Sterling
Memorial Library not part of the by
Nicki which is a distinct collection at
Yale but we are more or less the
university archives which is about
accounts for maybe half of our Holdings
that is every record financial minutes
of the corporation going back to 1701
and the repository for American history
Oracle political papers and this ranges
from papers such as the Eli Whitney
papers to the papers of AC Gilbert
usually people that do have a Yale
connection but we have a few others like
the walter Lippmann papers and probably
most famous are our papers of Charles
and Anne Morrow Lindbergh now Charles
Lindbergh was not a graduate phenom
estate now so how did those well it
seemed that wherever he turned in his
public life that he was connected with a
Yale man so I think he had especially
Juan Trippe the founder of Pan Am he
worked with Pan Am to found pan american
airlines and later became to know
kingman brewster in the later years so
there was always a Yale man who somehow
figured in fact he always said that the
reason he made it to Paris was that this
wonderful engine the first powerful
engine that could sustain a flight of
that long was invented by a Yale man
Charles Lawrence who got an honorary
degree for that and you referenced
earlier in your response that you have
documents that go back to the very first
year is that correct that's right I
guess the most famous Yale document
would be the first the minutes of the
first meeting of the corporation that
was in November of 7th of 1701 okay in
saybrook when they say we are founding
this college in order to train young men
for both the ministry and the state this
was very important because it meant that
Yale was not going to be a divinity
school or a religious college I mean
they realized from the very beginning
that you needed doctors lawyers all
professions but you needed a basis of a
liberal arts education and that's what
Yale still has at it as its core the BA
The Bachelor of Arts degree and that
from that you build on the professional
training or further academic training
that you need I'm glad you mentioned the
the religious affiliation though because
we also have a question from facebook
from a Gloria hoda who wants to
if there was ever a relationship between
Yale and the churches on the green yes
definitely with center church the center
church was the initial church founded by
Davenport it remained in the most purely
old-style congregational you had the
offshoot more Reformed Church which is
the united church next door and of
course eventually you have a church of
england sure to the episcopal church but
for many many years all of the
commencements were held in center church
and even today in the commencement
procession and you'll see that on May
twentieth the procession will walk from
the old campus well actually ends up at
the old campus but it will start in
front of the library go down around the
green and make a circle around Center
church and go back to the old campus
where the ceremonies are held so there
definitely was always a tie with the
Congregational Church for really over
200 years daily chapel was not abolished
at Yale until 1926 and that was only
because even with two sessions in the
morning they couldn't fit everybody in
so it had to become optional but there
isn't there is no religious tied to the
Congregational Church now so I want to
talk about handsome Dan I want to talk
about 19th century the origin of
collegiate baseball and I want to talk
about the yale bowl there's some good
sports stuff to talk about but first New
Haven how did it earn the nickname the
Elm City Elm City tradition really goes
back to the earliest days the Reverend
pierpont that I mentioned his home was
on the site where the oldest house in
New Haven is now the Yale visitor center
facing the Sun Elm Street that's a 149
elm street facing the green and
traditionally there were two Elms
planted in front of that his house and
that was where Jonathan Edwards accorded
the daughter of the Pierpont's and Sarah
Pierrepoint Oh became his wife and so
there was there came to be a tradition
of planting many Elms but it really
became very widespread when a man named
James Hill House a great entrepreneur
and beautifier of New Haven came forth
and
from his farm he had a farm on where
Hill House Avenue is and also a country
farm brought elm trees to lying in the
newly cut through street of Temple
Street and he continued then to plant
Elms all the way around the green and
also in front of of yale college because
we talked about Connecticut Hall that
was the foundation of the old brick row
the Yale of the 19th century at least
the earlier Bart did not have the
buildings in front of it that you see
today those Victorian Gothic heavy dark
structures they had a lawn that faced on
the green that was almost part of the
green you might say it's been argued
that Yale participated in the first
intercollegiate baseball game just after
the Civil War there's also a pretty good
case to be made for a game played a few
years earlier between amerson Williams
colleges in Massachusetts is this a
question that is likely to be settled
definitively and what do we know about
the first Yale game well I have delved
into the early history of most Yale
sports in fact the next article that
I've written that's coming out is on
wrestling it this is in the yellow M&Ms
is in the Yale alumni magazine now
baseball has an interesting history
because like some other games it took a
while for people to decide what the rule
should be which forms of the game they
liked and in Massachusetts Williams and
amorous played the game known as
Massachusetts baseball which was based
on a square instead of a diamond and led
to much higher scores I think that first
game was something like 73 to 30 but
that was one well this was in 1859
Amherst Williams game that's right and
then the civil war broke out and that's
when baseball truly became a national
sport because you had people in the
south and the north and they said
sometimes even North played south and
certain periods of law between battles
because they weren't always shooting
they weren't always shooting each other
and so the other form of baseball known
as New York baseball came to be the
favored game and that's the game that we
know today and
in the fall of 1865 after the war was
over Yale played Wesleyan in what's
called the first modern intercollegiate
God even so the scores were pretty high
I think Yale won something like thirty
nine to thirteen but it was it was a
different game played on a diamond and
with with more rules that did not allow
quite as many runs and that game was
played in New Haven I believe so yes
mm-hmm uh let's talk about the frisbee
the flying disc which also has a new
haven connection if I'm not yes well
frisbee was the game of the day when I
was in college and I first saw it played
actually on the Columbia lawns and so it
took a while for me to realize how
important it was in Yale history and it
all starts with the frisbee pie company
which of what place it was principally
in Bridgeport but without also had had a
plant in New Haven as well and the
frisbee pies were baked in very sturdy
tin pie plates that it was found had a
great aerodynamic quality and after you
finished the pie you could return the
pie pan to the store or the bakery and
get five cents but these became kept
more as just missiles and they would be
tossed in a game from student to student
and the idea was that they were pretty
lethal if you were in the way of one of
those because they were they were not
your thin aluminum pie pan of today that
they would shout frisbee and it was like
saying four and a go in a golf game is
this is this the 20th century the 19th
century there it's a deep and mysterious
question and someday we'll find a letter
or a diary the earliest we've heard
people say it goes back to about 19 20
the earliest it can be documented is in
the late 1930s when an alum said that he
had played frisbee and attested to it
but it definitely was a game that was
associated with the Yale and with the
pie plates the
modern frisbee and I should point out
there is a difference in spelling the
frisbee pies are bie with the game being
Vee and it was a plastic toy developed
in California beach toy that wham-o
thought was going to be have a great
future but they couldn't really market
it it was known as the first is the
flying saucer and then known as the
Pluto platter and it wasn't until the
president came east to the president the
president of wham-o richard nur and
heard about a game called frisbee that
was very similar except that it was just
played locally with these pie pans and
he thought well if they know that ivy
leaguers are playing this game that it's
just not a kid's beach toy this might
help our sales and so he renamed the toy
frisbee changing the spelling slightly
although conveniently the frisbee pie
company went out of existence in 1957
the same year that the frisbee became
wildly popular so popular in the spring
of 57 that it was written up in the New
York Times I want to ask you about a
gentleman called handsome Dan who if you
would explain who handsome Dan is and
and how what his origin is part of the
Yale ethos all right well it started
pretty simply with a freshman Andy
Graves who bought a bulldog from a
blacksmith in new haven in roughly what
time this was in eighteen eighty nine
okay and he loved this Bulldog it was
said that he bought it at the very dirty
dog at a blacksmith shop that just
appealed to him in New Haven and took
the dog home gave it a bath and when he
saw that it had a beautiful actually
white coat it wasn't gray and with brown
spots he said well you're a regular
handsome Dan and so that's how handsome
Dan got his name and he began bringing
him to the football games and gradually
taught him to bark at all the opposing
teams and most ferociously of course at
Harvard now he's handsome Dan the
official mascot
the University yes so handsome this
original handsome Dan continued on after
Andy left Yalie at a younger brother and
he left the dog with him but in in
nineteen in 1896 Andy was settled in
Britain permanently and he took the dog
away the dog died there in 97 and was
more into nine 1897 it was mourned
throughout the world at obituaries
attested that he had climbed the Alps
that he had done all these wonderful
feet so someone which may or may not
have became quite a character so the
mascot as a symbol and as a picture
remained there were posters there were
bulldog names written on the football
shirts but there was not another live
Bulldog until 1933 and that was handsome
Dan the second so since then they've all
been handsome Dan's and we're up to
number 17 I was going to ask is I heard
that there was one female and it was one
thing Daniella or I don't know what it
was I think she still was called a
handsome Dan but every Bulldog also has
a family name a name that they're called
by their keeper or people who know them
personally like the current one is
Sherman after Roger Sherman and the
female dog was bingo after the famous
bingo song bingo bingo Eli Yale I'm
going to take another question we've got
a question from a manual qwerty via
Facebook and he is interested to know if
there are certain women in Yale history
who have stood out so much that they
might be apt namesakes for say a new
residential college at the at the
University yes well there many names
have been suggested and the first woman
who actually got a degree from Yale was
in eighteen sixty eight from the law
school they never expected a woman to
apply so they did not have rules it said
woman women couldn't apply she applied
under her initials Alice roofie Jordan
and she was very quickly rushed through
in two years she got her degree so she's
been one that has been suggested as a
possible shape light on her initials be
cause because she knew that she would
not be admitted even though the rules
said didn't specify that you had to be a
man but no woman had attended Yale at
that time in 1869 the art school was
opened as a coed school so they were
there began to be many women who went to
Yale and some did become distinguished
artists but today the two names that are
mentioned the most in fact I would say
the outstanding name is Grace Hopper who
received a PhD in mathematics in 1932
she was the first woman Admiral in the
Navy and also at the forefront and the
development of the computer she
developed one of the early classic
computer languages COBOL and I think if
there is a college named after a woman
it would be after Grace Hopper by
American standards of course Yale as
we've discussed as a very old place and
it seems especially old downtown you
know in the center of the the old the
old campus in downtown new haven but
it's actually most of that is much newer
than it looks can you tell us a little
bit about when Yale adopted the
neo-gothic or collegiate gothic look and
how that all came about it really became
just the styles of the period and Yale
was one of the first to adopt this
modern gothic style you'll see it at
Princeton you'll also see it at
Northwestern principally but it was
probably the architect James gamble
rogers in connection with one of the
great donors the Harkness family edward
s Harkness once Harkness Tower was built
which is really probably the one great
icon symbol of of Yale the freestanding
tower that's on high street behind the
old it is and it is it is a hundred and
is 217 feet tall which is the age that
Yale was when the tower went up and that
really set the tone than for the future
residential colleges was that the first
the collegiate gothic style buildings
yes it was and the residential colleges
that followed all of those that face
that area of the tower were built in
that similar style they opened in 1933
product but if you get to the periphery
of the college's then you will see that
Georgian or federal style that's in four
of the colleges and and so the Georgia
and Federalist tile is that predate the
collegiate gothic it really it existed
in the old brick row these buildings
that were built in the earlier 19th
century that style went out of fashion
it was considered too simple or just oh
you might say like a cement block
building we would have been today and so
they began to build what they called
victorian gothic those buildings farnham
hall battelle chapel that you see
constituting the old campus then they
kind of moved into a classic period
where you see the university dining hall
Woolsey Hall that have a kind of Greek
temple looks that a lot of styles have
been used but I think people don't have
realized that the modern gothic in many
cases is only about 30 or to 40 years
older than the very modernistic
buildings that went up like the binding
key library Gibbs laboratory and the
Philip Johnson buildings and so on they
all are pretty much of an era of that
first first middle and and third of the
century strong link between Yale in the
city of New Haven the community the
greater community of South Central
Connecticut and and even through sports
the collegiate America of us of a
certain era is the yale bowl and i
believe the bowl is turning 100 next
year that's right in 14 yeah full of 14
do you have any thoughts on the
significance of the bowl not just for
Yale but sort of as a symbol of
something else well I think it's it's
symbolism hasn't evolved to a certain
extent I mean football was the sport
that put Yale on the map there were
other sports that were important rowing
was the first sport and rowing in
America
she began in the New Haven Harbor as
early as 18 43 but it was Walter Camp
who was born right here on Chapel Street
who developed the modern rules of
football out of the rough and tumble
game of English rugby and football all
started as I say in New Haven the we
have a wonderful letter from Walter Camp
to Notre Dame Notre Dame says we'd like
to start a good football team here in
1892 please send us your best rules so
thousands and thousands of people came
first by train and then by automobile so
they knew that they needed a bigger
stadium and when the yale bowl opened it
was the largest Amphitheatre that had
been built since the Roman Colosseum it
held upwards of about 70,000 people
sometimes could hold even more when
extra bleachers were were put up in
front but each time it has been
renovated it's all it holds fewer people
as people have grown larger through
through the ages we're we're sort of
starting to run out of time but I want
to get to a few more questions so let me
get your thoughts on this one from from
Robin who asks and this is very much a
new haven question about the oyster
trade and how significant that was in
the development of new haven or how
significant it was as part of the
economy and specifically what territory
did the oyster trade cover at its at its
peak and if you can squeeze all this
into just a minute or so what what the
architectural antecedents might be for
some of the oyster mins cottages that
are still around at Fair Haven well of
course I think a lot of them seem to
have a kind of double decker or higher
quality because the boats could come
right up on the banks of the river there
and most of the time the oysters could
be shocked right in you know right in
the lower level of these houses usually
by the women of the house the oystering
industry has definitely had its
and downs I mean oysters were very
plentiful as even with lobsters and all
shellfish and they were really food for
the common folk if you couldn't eat
anything else you go out and dig
yourself there were slams or oysters it
was free food for the most part but then
later in the 19th century it suddenly
became a desirable luxury food in New
York and the New York beds of that
supplied most of these oysters actually
got used up and so this left more and
more opportunity in the later 19th
century for other places and new haven
on the Long Island Sound I mean today
the famous one is the Blue Point oysters
which is also which is from Long Island
the New Haven side with the pollution
and the industry because New Haven was
also a port city still is tended to make
people scared with health hazards over
time and the industry changed from
actually harvesting full fully grown
osters to becoming seed beds and that
has kind of struggled along over the
years too it's been hoped they were
training i believe prisoners at one time
thinking that when they came out this
would be a good way to earn a living and
it still has some hopes but mostly we
have it in the sense of history with
those wonderful houses in fairhaven well
this next question from a gentleman
called Lucas Barton pertains also to
food he notes that in your 1997
introduction to Stover at Yale you
mentioned several private eating clubs
in operation at the turn of I guess the
20th century where were these located do
any of the building still exists he'd
like to know and do you have much in the
way of archival document photographs of
well most of the so-called eating clubs
were almost really like boarding houses
because first of all there weren't
enough rooms to how's everybody
residential maserati's Central College
so only about half the students were
usually able to fit into the dorms at
any one period of time until they built
the residential colleges they're just
they couldn't keep up with the growing
size of the college and even if you
lived in a college you didn't want to
eat in Yale Commons when there was a
dying
hall so they would hire a cook or a
manager who would provide food and that
was a way for poorer boys actually to go
through Yale they would manage a food
club and it would be like you know you
go eaten in and you'd eat family-style
for you for your meals and one of the
most famous in a way I mean that evolved
into that was Maurice which was
originally a bar actually and not some
lady's home where the cooking was done
but that was mrs. Moriarity who did run
it kind of like a an eating Club you
would say she was famous for her welsh
rabbits and her soups and and it was
called Maurice quiet house because she
did not want any loud rambunctious
that's going on and so in 1909 that
became probably the most famous eating
so is Maurice yes so is more as the the
sort of sole survivor of those as it
were I would say so now there are senior
societies that we don't always know a
lot about because some people call them
secret societies and many of them do
serve food at least on some nights
usually two nights a week and some of
them serve lunches and breakfasts as
well we're going to take one more
question this is from Aaron who notes
that the the school of Forestry and
environmental studies has oak leaves and
acorns on its school shield and asks
about the significance of that well the
shields heraldic shields are really just
a kind of modern almost satire you might
say on English heraldry they were
invented from the 1930s through the
1960s mainly by a professor of art
history not known as cubby sizer
Theodore sizer and in like the name
Trumbull has three bulls tribal and so
some of them have a basis in real
heraldry others are just figurative and
so it was using the the woodland imagery
to make that of course and so I would
just say and some of them have been
changed by design of some of the masters
or Dean's that are associated with these
schools and areas who who have wanted to
make some
movements on them Trudy chef thank you
so much for sharing your incomparable
knowledge of Yale's history with us
today I mean I'm sure you could go on
for hours on any one of these subjects
and some of us would love to hear that
so I hope perhaps you'd join us again in
the future thank you a new haven and
Yale both have great histories thanks to
all of you for tuning in for this
episode of at Neil live with fruity
shift we'll look forward to seeing you
next time bye bye